now that i'm back i was thinking about
it today i feel like i never left i
really think i know this city like the
back of my hand
i really do yeah but are you really sure
about that i mean you haven't lived here
in in a while andy i don't think that
matters i think
i think nobody knows more about new york
city
than i do i think i
i i really do i think the city's in my
blood
nobody there's not a single person in
the world who could know more about new
york city than i do real yes
really
well conan then you should have no
trouble passing the just invented new
york city citizenship test administered
by new york's own the one the only mr
john stewart
right here
lovely to see
thank you so much
oh wow
how are you how are things going in that
1940s gas station you're working
i'll tell you it was going great it's
been a terrible traffic jam this giant
ginger-haired rack
and you know this town man uh new york
city what can you do it's this town new
york city is this town by the way you
don't lose your citizenship of new york
when you leave it you you are always and
will always be
very citizen of new york that being said
uh you don't know
about this place
and you never did never did and i've got
a quiz that i think can yeah you know
what john your your quiz does not
frighten me
perhaps it's because
you wrote it so let's
let's get to it
let's get back into the premise here we
go here we go
conan i've got a question for you let's
start simple okay
why do you
that was very insulting what you did
let's start simple meaning
just love between two people okay
conan o'brien how many boros are there
in new york city easy five
i'm gonna do this like there's only one
uh question on each card yeah even
though that's not the trick yeah okay
[Applause]
what's the population of manhattan easy
1.6 million
[Applause]
i just want to make it very clear
no one has any idea how many people are
in here
it's a completely made-up thing all
right
what new york city institution holds
representatives
of more than
193 nations the f train
now here's one
this is a bit of arcane trivia he's done
very well up to now
why is the mayor's residence called
gracie mansion because the house was
originally the home of early american
businessman archibald mansion
we can edit that one all right
i can't imagine what you'll say to this
where in new york city is the ball
dropped every year
city field
that again
isn't it interesting
how quickly a good audience
can turn into a meth meth-fueled zombie
apocalypse
complete this new york city proverb if a
crowded subway has one seat free there
you'll find a homeless man's pee yes
[Applause]
you're getting these all right
every single one name the very famous
new york resident
you do this one
name the very famous new york resident
who won the 2016 presidential election
hillary clinton right
they turned on you and now they're back
they would have ripped me limb from limb
honestly
one more new york mets reference they
would have lipped you
limb from limb they would have ripped
you they would have and and lipped me
cut out your brain
yeah but now they're back
you knew you were back in new york conan
o'brien when i saw pizza rat getting
into an uber black
here's a series of questions that i
think you'll find very amusing okay
give the appropriate new york response
to the following situations you're
almost hit by a cab i'm walking here
you're christopher walken i'm walking
here
[Applause]
you're a plumber applying waterproof
sealant
to a bathtub i'm caulking here
by the way i
this is
applauding your ability to rhyme
what is the best way to get a child into
a manhattan preschool has the child been
born yes yes it's already too late
now this one is a little more difficult
this one is something that uh is going
to have to be written in red if you're
going to be able to read it um
i'm going to give you a hypothetical
news story and i want you to tell me
what the new york post headline would be
okay i can do this
really fake concentrate yeah all right
yeah
trump fire special counsel robert
mueller bye bye bobby
mayor de blasio mired in a corruption
scandal mayor mcsleeves
thomas keller's new vietnamese
restaurant opens to poor reviews vietnam
nom noms by tombaum
that was an easy warning
come on
this is a man who earns millions of
dollars
hundreds of thousands
[Laughter]
what is the name of the pastry that
combines a croissant with a donut a
cronut what is a croissant combined with
a muffin a cruffin what is an avocado
and a waffle an awful what
banana bread a fritter and a danish a
friend dresser uh
[Applause]
we'll take care of that
you won't be seeing that around
going into the archive yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right here we go that's why i should
have went to him
give the definition of these thomish
yiddish common yiddish words
putts uh putts a jerk or a fool also a
penis
schmuck a jerk or a fool also a penis
schlep to carry your travel with
difficulty as in that schmuck schlepped
his putts all the way through prospect
park also a penis
[Applause]
and what my friend is the easiest way to
kiss up to a crowd bring out a legendary
comedian have him ask softball questions
about their city
and with that in mind
with that in mind yes
the final question is this
new york city has the greatest audiences
in the world